c'était quel type de relation avec
Johnny Depp en fait c'est un animal de
Johnny déjà tous les matins il arrive
avec une humeur différente il y a
parfois des humeurs où il est très
joyeux il a envie de d'essayer plein de
choses de rigoler avec les gens et tout
ça et il y a des moments où il n'en a
pas envie faut savoir quand même que
c'est quelqu'un qui est tout le temps
exposé qui sortait de deux procès moi je
peux comprendre moi quand je reçois un
recommandé déjà je suis nouée toute la
journée donc j'imagine que lui il y
avait des moments où on était très
complice évidemment c'est pas dans ces
moments là que les médias s'y
intéressent il a été dit que c'était
l'enfer c'était faux c'était pas du tout
l'enfer il y a eu des désaccords mais
comme sur tous les tournages comme dans
toutes les entreprises comme partout
ailleurs dès lors que vous passez de moi
ensemble toute la journée avec des
horaires qui sont très lourds c'est
obligé qu'il y ait des désaccords